welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of ms
marvel episode 3 which gives kamala 10
rings problems in a gymnate one i don't
know that made sense but let's break
down this episode shot by shot for all
the marvel easter eggs and details you
might have missed because there is so
much to explain from the opening minutes
of this episode also announcement that
you can see new rock stars live in
austin texas on saturday july 2nd as
part of rtx that's rooster teeth's
podcast festival for discounted tickets
click the link in the description use
the code new rockstar is all one word
it's gonna be a lot of fun we hope to
see you there don't miss it we opened in
british occupied india in 1942 making
this a few years before the partition
mentioned last episode that's when the
british left india by dividing it into
india and pakistan resulting in
devastating civil unrest we find
ourselves in a cave contained in various
ancient relics digging through this
rubble is najma faria salim and kamala's
long-lost great grandmother aisha i
found the bangle
should we be concerned it's on a severed
arm you heard what that man from the
temple said
he said we would need two so where's the
other one
i told you the british have probably
looted this place twice over by now and
as the british army realizes their
intrusion they burn down this location
and we get this overhead shot revealing
the floor is carved with the symbol of
the ten rings
but really the key detail here is that
they find this bangle on a severed blue
arm which indicates to us that it may be
cree cree are humanoid extraterrestrials
in the marvel cinematic universe many of
whom are blue skinned creeping the
society that carol danvers ended up with
and captain marvel most of them are
imperialist pricks cree technology is
partially the source of carol danvers
power up it was a light speed engine
powered by the tesseract the space stone
followed by a bit of cree transfusion it
was the cree who invented the terrigen
mist the process that creates inhumans
and what gave kamala her powers in the
comics so this 10 rings logo might mark
this as the location when wu discovered
the ten rings in the comics the ten
rings are alien mcluhan technology
discovered by the mandarin and the
wreckage of a mcclewian ship the shanxi
film only hints at where when wu found
these rings
[Music]
so this place may be that tomb or crater
where when wu found the rings these
rings were extraterrestrial technology
but not from the mcluhan's like they are
in the comics but in the mcu from the
cree this could be a cree crash site
containing other relics of ancient creek
technology this group sent here by a man
in the temple whom i believe to be
win-woo when wu has had the rings for
over a thousand years and this helmet
that barria finds looks like the kind
worn by the tin rings cavalry in that
shang chi prologue or at least worn by
an army that they conquered we are in
the indian subcontinent here but the ten
rings empire spanned the whole asian
continent from china to afghanistan many
have speculated that bengal is connected
to the tin rinks because if you look
closely it does illuminate very
similarly to the way the tin rings do
remember in the shang chi post credits
scene wang banner and carol danvers
analyze those rings they're not
vibranium
chittari
not like any alien tech i've seen
how long did your dad have them before
he gave them to you
about a thousand years
their thermoluminescence indicates
they're older than that now carol might
be familiar with modern cree tech but if
these rings were ancient cretech it
would predate any expertise that she had
so i believe ancient cree sent a
dispatch to earth thousands of years ago
perhaps alerted by the arrival of the
eternals or maybe the even earlier
arrival of a vibranium meteorite to
wakanda which i think was the nexus
moment that really gave the true birth
of civilization and technology to this
planet in the mcu i think that ancient
creed dispatch could have brought with
them the ten rings and the two bengals
maybe also technology like pterogenesis
sometime after that the rings were
recovered by win woo maybe there was
some kind of conflict where he severed
the arm of that warrior with the bengal
so why now would win will give this
group valuable information maybe it
wasn't win-woman maybe it was a rival of
his but remember in chiang chi nan
explained the realm of talo we have
cities that surpass any in your universe
rich with culture and history
thousands of years ago
all of our people lived in peace and
prosperity
until the attack of the dweller in
darkness so this implies that the
dweller of darkness must have come from
some dimension beyond tallow as these
folks are interdimensional beings from
beyond when wu might have made a deal
with these devils for him to keep the
ten rings so that they could take the
bangles now the most important detail
from that post-credits scene was that
the ten rings were released in some kind
of pulsing beacon that was summoning
something or someone now i think it will
be revealed to be the cree as the
rightful owners of this technology this
being a very important relic to their
culture and with secret invasion coming
up i think we're gonna learn about the
cree squirrel shadow war that's been
happening behind the scenes and that's
gonna erupt into an all-out cosmic war
in which carol kamala and monica are
gonna have to defend earth from a crete
invasion i think that is going to be the
plot line of the marvels next year so
where is the other bangle faria says the
british had already looted this tomb
which is an important clue it could be
in one of those london museums we
visited recently where cersei and dane
worked or where stephen grant worked or
where killmonger visited that relic
could be among the possessions of dane's
uncle along with the ebony blade that we
saw in the eternal's post-credits scene
it could be an artifact held by mi 13
the supernatural investigation division
where blade and black knight have both
worked and we know the two of them are
now together from that post-credit scene
or it could be in damage control storage
along with the chitari tech and the
ultron heads that we saw in spider-man
homecoming aisha snaps on this bangle
her eyes turned purple as they did for
kamala presumably she got a glimpse of
that nor dimension as kamala did but
because aisha was from that dimension
she cannot fully connect with this
bengal the way kamala can since she was
born in this dimension then we jump to
the present where we realized najma has
been telling this story to kamala and
najma reveals that she and aisha and the
others were exiled from another
dimension called the nor dimension nor
meaning light and they all have some
degree of nor in them but in lesser
quantities still slowing down their
aging however komron is 17 years old so
don't worry no one's going to jail well
he doesn't go to jail this episode but
you know not for that nashville says the
bagel helped kamala unlock her nor and
maybe someday something will help
cameron unlock his hinting that he will
probably power up into his blue
bioluminescent in human form from the
comics then we meet the last one of
their group who's only hinted at the
opening scene his name is adam welcome
don't mind him
we've been around for a hundred years
and he picks the stupidest parts of
humanity to be obsessed with that's so
rude his name being adam is significant
as when they argue off-screen the
captions show he says this is his house
he's more confident than the others and
there might be some significance to that
because najma says in our home dimension
the newer dimensions
were known as clandestines as to what we
are we've been called
ajnabi
unseen the list goes on
but what we're most commonly known as is
jin i'm sorry did you just say jin
okay wow so the term jin was actually
mentioned back in episode one please
tell bruno this zuzu is possessed by the
evil jinn he needs to fix it jin refers
to a spirit or a demon in islamic
mythology actually pre-islamic mythology
as yusuf clears up later they've been
anglicized as genies which basically
just means white culture says bastardize
this culture they've turned the concept
into like jacked blue will smith rapping
but jin absolutely have a deeper lore to
them the idea is that whereas humans
were understood to be made from clay the
jinn was made from smokeless fire and
are forbidden to interact with humans
and are actually invisible to us by the
way the other terms that najma mentioned
ashnabi is arabic for strange alien or
foreign is turkish for a crazy person
unseen may have a deeper meaning to it
marvel lore unseen has been considered
to be invisible to the watchers but i
think she was using it in the context
that jyn are supposed to be invisible to
mortals but the key word there was
clandestine which was capitalized and i
think might be referring to a
lesser-known group in marvel comics from
the 90s founded by adam of ravencroft
adam later dubbed adam of destin from
12th century england who during the
crusades fell in love with a gin their
descendants become the clandestine all
with various different powers and they
team up with the x-men and don't feel
bad if you don't know they existed
because they were never popular i
guarantee you even the nerdiest marvel
fan who watched this episode today had
to do a bit of googling to figure out
who these guys were but i think that was
by design their obscurity and their
intersection with gin mythology being
the reason why this term was chosen here
now to be clear this group is only 100
years old really it's their extra
dimensional status and the fact that
they identify with being jin something
important to pre-islamic mythology being
far more important to who they are in
this story the fact that the biggest
a-hole in the group is named adam i
think just a nod to adam a ravencroft
adam of destin i'm thinking that their
nor dimension is actually another
spiritual afterlife realm in the mcu
alongside the ancestral plane in the
duat as tuaret and moon knight explained
that both the duat and the ancestral
plane were part of an array of
interlinked afterlives that all take
different forms based on the beliefs of
the individual and now to be clear the
concept of the jinn far predates 100
years when these exiles arrived into our
dimension so really jin is just what
they were called and how they explain
what they are but they are not literally
gin and it remains a mystery why they
were exiled and what it says about that
dimension that authorities there exile
souls from that realm and leave us with
them what i love most about all this is
that it is grounding the mythology of
kamala khan and the whole khan family
and her powers in faith that seems to be
a thematic undercurrent of phase four
with stories like thor love and thunder
eternals moon night and soon black
panther wakanda forever all exploring
the theme of how for many of these
characters being a superhero is deeply
intertwined with their spiritual beliefs
and i think this is awesome because the
mcu may be about to establish that all
paranormal folklore beings in this world
vampires ghosts demons werewolves
bigfoots chupacabras musks our exiles
from other spiritual realms other
dimensions and assuming one of those
dimensions is hell i guess we got a
pretty good look at that and doctor
strange's multiverse of madness you know
what that means now if you're full of
chivalry and really want to address
someone as lord and lady established
titles can make it official established
titles is a project based on a historic
scottish custom where landowners are
referred to as lairds or lords and
ladies in english they let people buy as
little as one square foot of dedicated
land so that they can call themselves a
lord or lady and in return established
titles commits to planting a tree it's
just a really fun way to help preserve
the beautiful woodlands and biodiversity
of scotland while supporting global
affordation efforts established titles
work with global charity trees for the
future and one tree planted to help them
plant a tree for every order plus for
those with scottish heritage out there
it's just a great way to connect to your
family roots your certificate features a
unique plot number with which you can
see the exact location of your land on a
private estate in edelston scotland and
an official certificate with a crest you
can get a couple pack for you and your
partner with adjoining plots of land and
you can literally have this gift ready
in five minutes so what makes an amazing
last minute gift and established titles
is actually running a massive sale right
now plus if you use the code new
rockstars you get an additional 10 off
so go to
establishtitles.comrockstars to get your
gifts now and help support this channel
not today though now the opening title
includes kamala's notepad drawing
showing captain marvel with a heart on
her chest iron man with the heart on his
chest and palm repulsor hulk and then
this sexy dude going aha
another is cut paper with kk labelled on
the scissors and then another is a
drawing of kamala totally falling over
comrade also quick reminder the best way
to support rockstars is to get our ms
marvel inspired cosmic daydream shirt at
newrockstarsmerch.com where you'll get
the added option to write in a custom
shout out for our miss marvel after
shows come on let tries to explain this
all to bruno i'm jay
and tonic solid joke i love it the books
on bruno's shelf include mechanical
behavior of materials turning the wheel
hacking darwin how to manage your mother
how the mind works mr monster and on top
of an issue of popular science kamala
asks do you know anything about
interdimensional travel off the top of
your head specifically the nord
dimension that's n-o-o actually no that
reminds me of a paper i read
uh i think it's by dr excellent perfect
yes eric selvig thor and jane foster's
astrophysicist buddy from the thor films
and age of ultron and now based on the
in-flight movies and spider-man far from
home something of a neil degrasse tyson
figure in the mcu bruno shows kamala
that she's trending that tick-tock post
from a guy named miguel with hashtags
including mosque save girl on roof night
light and jersey city hero dodc agent
dever's license plate is zero one zero
two e e in one of vision wanda envisions
license plate when they first drove into
west view in episode one was zero one
zero two she struts into the mosque her
shoes making hard thuds on that
carpeting just so rude of her in these
agents to enter with their shoes on
nakia tells them to get a warrant knock
not about
mosque board member we still have a few
more votes to count okay all right
perspective
member but i feel good about our polling
yeah there is a lot of adr in this
episode that's where they bring in
actors afterwards to dub in audio that
they just kind of layer in in
post-production and by the way they do
that all the time in movies and tv shows
usually it's very subtle but this one
was totally my favorite nakia's
political rival wanted to make sure all
the votes were counted a detail that i
love because if you think about it
kamala's rescue in the eid festival when
they campaigned was the day before so
when was this election held during the
festival this morning at the meeting how
many people voted how long were the
polls open i mean this guy is totally
right to demand some election security
here kamala watches the tick tock video
on her desktop that's weird the comments
include a bunch of little easter eggs
including one from queen zainaia she
could save me anytime one from royal
ruby nightlight saves people left and
right the real euro king saying captain
marvel wannabe and i assume this is
actually najaf the euro vendor humming
drizzle replies to him saying yeah she
can't even fly hurricane also comments i
don't know what everyone is so hyped
about she broke the kid's leg but then
beneath that gw not the bridge defends
her saying she saved him he would have
fallen without her now gw could refer to
ms marvel co-creator g willow wilson or
maybe the guidance counselor mr wilson
named after her and then there's a
comment from fizz on the man and the
real zoe zimmer oh zoey you always just
gotta be where it's happening don't you
outside of the party kamala has this
heart to heart with her chic who advises
good it's not a thing you are kamala
[Music]
it is a thing you do yes reminding
kamala that her status as a great
granddaughter of a clandestine is really
irrelevant it's her own choices now that
define her we see bruno has given kamala
a superhero mask and he put it in a shoe
box if you look at the side of that shoe
box it is size 13 men damn bruno in the
circle q bruno studies celtics paper on
his laptop and you can see an einstein
rose in bridge illustration aka a
wormhole and he refers to the events of
new york city in 2012 aka the battle of
new york something he was very involved
with considering loki used the mind
stone on him there's also some language
asking if we should leave this dimension
or not dr selvik doing the work that
soon characters like reed richards and
kang will be building on yusuf drops in
for a hostess fruit pie which is a
classic marvel comics deep cut for when
like spider-man or the avengers would
randomly plug hostess fruit pies in
panels a very forced and cringy thing
that marvel comics used to do as yusuf
hints out with this meta line there's
just something about their syntheticness
i just can't resist them
yousef translates some urdu text about
the gin legend tells of a group of
hidden chin
exiled from their home world
and damned to live out their days
trapped in our own
they move in shadows
searching for the key
that will help them get home
but to unlock such an ancient barrier
will require a primordial power later
with bruno kamala wears an iron man
shirt and rubs her knee telling us that
her nord doesn't necessarily give her
rapid healing powers bruno tells her
that they'd need the energy the size of
the sun to open a portal through
dimensions which could wreak havoc on
this dimension kamala says carol dammers
went away
she'd punch a hole in space and time and
she'd help them now and carol danvers
would be reckless
maybe it's not such a bad thing that
you're not her yeah i'm so glad someone
said it avengers including captain
marvel are not good role models higher
fest further baby also i'm sorry i
burned the city down oh well when kamala
texts comrade a qr code appears to her
left on the wall every episode there is
a hidden qr code somewhere in the shot
where if you scan it with your phone
it'll take you to a link that actually
updates every week with a new free miss
marvel comic this week it's the
magnificent miss marvel number one from
2019 which frames kamala as a bedtime
story hero called the destined one this
episode's title is destined all the
story beats this episode with the family
wedding all the heart to hearts between
maneeba and kamala between yzip and amir
they're all just so wholesome and sweet
and wonderful we get to learn so much
about the family in this culture and it
is a delight one detail that i really
liked is amir being shoeless throughout
the event this is actually a game ritual
called choo choo chuptai in which the
groom's shoes are stolen and the crew
must beg or pay ransom to get them back
before he can leave the venue my dumb
theory this week is that nick fury got
his shoes stolen on the skrull space
station because he was currently getting
married that day to a south asian woman
probably wrong probably wrong i just
want to know why they took his shoes and
during the amazing dance sequences the
illness the nephew is wearing the padded
hulk outfit the minivan stitch for
kamala and yousef in episode 1. the
wedding band is brown jovi a bon jovi
cover band calling back the family's
love of the new jersey prince in the
past episode cameron shows up to warn
kamala but also to screw over bruno he
knows his name isn't brian there's
legitimate jealousy there and as i
mentioned before some of his lines here
were definitely picked up later via adr
kill everyone you have to get out with
him hey
i think you should leave marla everyone
will die i am guessing that an earlier
cut of this episode didn't properly have
cameron establishing the life or death
stakes of najma's crew but also are they
gonna kill everyone we don't really know
what the clandestine's power set was
they don't really seem that scary a lot
of this part seemed a bit hastily added
together but still there's a lot to love
here like the amazing needle drop to
have bon jovi's living on a prayer
during this chaos this whole episode
establishes kamala's powers as grounded
in her spiritual beliefs she is
literally living on a prayer now at
first i actually thought brown joby kept
playing through this which would be nuts
but you can see them running off in the
chaos but still that means they set
their break music to continue to play
and those break tracks are all bon jovi
songs which is also really funny another
little detail here after worrying about
not having enough money in his bank
account during this panic amir smartly
goes through the cash and grabs it off
the plate the clandestines turn out to
be a real bunch of a-holes adam straight
up punches a cook who wasn't even in his
way
[Music]
absolutely not
ah i love that extra give her a spin off
there are some goofy signs posted
throughout this kitchen like on the dry
erase board 63 days without incident how
bad was that incident where they had to
keep track of their days without one
then a teal sign on the walk-in cooler
that says please do not enter this
cooler unless you specifically need
something in here this cooler is to
remain locked at all times whoa yikes i
assume they also meant to put up a sign
that says also please refrain from
saying the words longing rusted furnace
daybreak because we keep winter soldiers
frozen in here what the hell and yes we
do not really get a clear sense of the
clandestine's power set they seem to
have some super strength like they crack
the floor tile and see kamala flying
after they punch her nora shield adam
taps a chest pendant transforming it
into a melee weapon but that shot is so
dimly lit that we can't really make out
this transfiguration berea just shows up
with a spear celine turns his belt into
this whip-like blade i think this is
actually a bendable blade called nurumi
cameron and najma both have weapons but
we don't really see where they tap them
from i mean hey it wouldn't be disney
plus without a mid season moment right
it especially just feels a little lame
when they can all get taken out by dodc
hulk sonic cannons and then get arrested
like scooby doo villains i mean no
offense to these clandestines i just
don't blame the nord dimension for being
like
we're good we're good you stay out we do
get a cool moment where kamala's nor
light and biggens her fist to punch
saleem and say bruno and then her arm
just stretches to clear the room there's
a very important moment where najib
grabs kamala's bengal and a portal opens
showing the train with karachi on it it
is a steam engine train something from
the 40s i am thinking the clandestines
betrayed aisha by pushing her in front
of that train after aisha refused to
disclose that she gave that bengal to
sana nakia realizes kamala is that
nightlight hero she's been mad at and
she completely savages bruno nakia will
take care of me wait no just go kamala
refuses to admit to her family that she
did pull the fire alarm and ruin the
wedding and then her nani sana calls
telling kamala that she and muniva need
to come to karachi asap did you see the
train beta you have to come to karachi
and that is where we will go next
episode where we will likely meet the
red dagger or who knows that this raid
maybe we'll meet blade i have no idea
where this show is going and i kind of
love that hey if you live in the san
francisco bay area you can come see me
live with in games improv every other
saturday including this saturday june
25th hit me up on twitter for more
details at
voss follow new rockstars subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you